you've ridiculed cryptos you've stood on
the sidelines with the institutional
investors
in your hamptons home you've stood there
uh
with a lot of the large banks this is
something that has surprised
many of us you instead of embracing the
crypto revolution you didn't
really embrace uh a lot of the wall
street bat stuff you stood
with your blue bloods in newport rhode
island in greenwich connecticut
in the hamptons now and i'm i'm asking
you a question now
you you'd constantly are just defending
the old guard
all right you also have a legacy and i
get it but
can you speak on this can you speak on
your resistance
let's get something clear i lost blood
in wall street's best how much did you
lose
250 about 250 dollars yeah i got out
you know but i got it i got out because
you know i was like um
it's like you guys i i i have hope i'm
the rare cynic
who can have hope yes i watch more of a
movie like cry
yeah i lose some money on wall street
yeah because you're crying because
you're being tased you're watching it
through the window of someone else's
home
and there's security approaches i don't
have cable yeah um
so look it's everything
looks great now and i look like a big
idiot and look i don't personally care
because i'm not the guy
regardless of whether i think it's good
or not like i don't think uh
did you see the bill maher piece on it i
did see it
um his reasoning was a little uh
just old man yelling at the sun kind of
thing yes but
it wasn't totally he wasn't totally
wrong he's like ethereum
has more market cap than disney and it
has no pro
you know what i mean it's like yeah but
it's just he's such a horrible
conduit of information he's such a
hateable person
every time i talk about this i am every
comment section of me
and every like i'm the big fat [ __ ] who
doesn't understand
i'm making 10 year old arguments let's
get something included the arguments
were never addressed
because they can't be addressed right uh
this is not
well you know how i'll address
right now make one of your arguments
against crypto i'm going to address it
right now
in my opinion who i am now with my
ray-bans and my miami hat
okay here's one here's a new one i have
yeah
other people have it so we have like at
least four cryptos that are really
like capped up right five a ton
a bunch are they all gonna be currency
how about you go [ __ ] your mother
but are they all gonna be be ask me
is it a good idea to let people that are
buying houses defer interest
it's a good idea to allow people who are
buying houses hey
go [ __ ] your mother
see that's the response that stops
people like you in your tracks
because you come we're having a party
right this is the thing about a party
people are trying to ruin a party
this is a party during a high school
party
when you're fingering your friends and
if you're like me you're hugging your
friends because they won't [ __ ] you
whatever if you're in the middle of a
high school party and people are drunk
and everybody's senior year nobody comes
up to you and goes
do you think we'll all be as close when
we're in college
and that's what you're doing you're
coming up to people at a party and going
what's tomorrow at 3 p.m gonna be like
and you're like dude i don't know
but it's [ __ ] 1am now and it's lit
so i my argument is that [ __ ] is lit no
they're not all gonna be currencies
bitcoin is the reserve currency and all
the other currencies are going to be
little fun things that people
can enjoy and possess and find whatever
value they find in them
okay but that's inherently an argument
against them
no i mean it's fine oh it's
it's a troll though cool it's a digital
troll though
it's an opportunity for people to
believe again
it's a beanie we need a bitcoin movie
where they give a field of dream speech
someone needs to get up and go like you
know the town you know the scene of
tommy boy where they're talking to the
workers that have all been and they're
like
in this town this factory i remember we
need a speech where a guy's like this
has given
people a chance to believe again people
that were riding
not two months ago people who were
smashing the windows of the capitol
this is they were marching in
charlottesville this is giving them
a new thing to talk about
it's better than that isn't it better
than wearing viking horns yes or yes
i i'm not saying bitcoins all all right
people stop it
because i know that's the [ __ ] new
york times angle that all these crypto
shits are
but it is anti-establishment people and
it should be anti-establishment people
who are actually
doing quite well in the system to begin
with a lot of the time dave portnoy is a
struggling
farmer so and so is elon musk
so stop stop this argument that this is
incredibly wealthy people
duping people that spend all day
looking at their computer these are good
men who are
struggling look i mean i i hear you here
here
i i don't know that the american psyche
what it needs most right now is hope
i think you know i think fair point pope
is kind of the the the
the antecedent they were to to
self-reflection i think we need a little
more self-reflection a little less hope
but that being said i'm all for those
i'm doing we need a little party
we need a party and we're having a party
and i think we haven't worked hard
wait where is this hard work that we're
paying we're like celebrating
parties never are the result of hard
work
that's a good point good parties hard
workers don't parties good parties are
actually
better when the people there haven't
worked at all
the work is the party do you understand
they're putting all the work into the
party
partying is a job for people people you
know we go out this guy last night after
show or even kirk hatches at 2 am he
goes
he goes tomorrow night you want to go
out you want to get into something what
circles you guys want to get into i'm
like this guy's married i'm sober
i'm exhausted i just did two shows there
is no partying i'm 36.
what am i gonna do i don't want to stand
in a room full of people and hear their
[ __ ] anymore
i've done i'm just done i was 23
i went to parties where they said sure
were they christmas parties at mortgage
companies yes was i drinking with people
twice my age yes
was i getting laid no was i [ __ ] you
know living
uh the life of a 45 year old divorced
man when i was 22
sure but whatever i was supposed to be
doing
it didn't happen i went to the city and
danced a few times at clubs
i get it but 30 [ __ ] six
enough's enough already we gotta move
the [ __ ] on
what i'd like now is a little
cryptocurrency
uh and just some quiet